so uh
Let's start out jason with that time jump. I mean shows you times up sometimes, but six years is a big one
You know why did you decide you know let's let's do this now
I mean we've talked before about the show actually it was a pretty condensed time period For the characters tonight
You're leaping forward. What does it feel like okay? Let's let's do this down
Well, we talk a lot last season about how the world would not be
Survivable for five years and so because I know he's got heated wearing hazmat suits
Figure let's jump ahead, so they could come out without a contractors. Thank you actually we can ad shows it on a car
I wait what can you say about that prisoner ship?
Because that's a whole new element add to the serious point well without spoiling too much of
the prison ship there from her
I think I've heard some speculation that maybe they weren't
And it's there from our time so they're from for the first apocalypse. Which is a spoiler, but
Okay
And that is that huge probably cry over they were in hypersleep?
For a hundred years. I think that was planted in certain episodes last year that they have that time
Capability so they come back to the planet that they don't recognize that it has been destroyed
I just left it twice and all that left is this garden of eden that Clark's been living in with her daughter
You know it will not be big enough for everybody
So the lines let's talk about Maddie who's not her biological daughter
But we talked about what do you think about the time jump, but here they're doing it and about this new character
That's gonna be so crucial to clark. Well. I've been playing a nineteen-year-old
For years since I was 23, so it's like it's nice to be a three playing
someone a little close to my age
We were going to get away with that
and
Yet, I think it's exciting to see you know
It will be there's like you know me and as I guess being a 24 year old woman
Who has gone through so much and she's taking on this paternal role looking after this little tiny knifeless?
Bob you know with when clark thought she might not make it which are not to be the truth
You know she kind of was passing on leadership to him to bellamy you know
He's gone through a lot up prior to that
You know didn't think this was a challenge he had risen to in those six years
I'd like to think that he had I think the
He has taken the advice as a hit in the heart. I mean from what I've been told
I don't know that much other so I guess from what up. What Jason is told me if he can be trusted
penelope has
Grown up a little bit I think
But yeah that sixties on jumps kind of crazy becoming six months for us
But we got to figure out what they've done to their lost cookies and on this character p.m.. Yeah
Yeah, yeah, it got to be a reset sort of for all you guys and murray with Octavia
I mean she was put in charge of a lot of people and we saw in the finale the
insecurity she had about that and she was a character was so much sort of on the fringe and
Literally had to hide her most of her life
What do you think it's been like her to now be in a spotlight in this way after all the sort of on the one
um I think
Octavia doesn't have a clue what she's doing, but she doesn't wanna you know set off the Chaos with this 1200 people
In the bunker because it was her idea to throat have one crew and have this mixed bag of plans and of course
They're not wanting to let go of previous animosity that they have for one another
so just
similar to
The way she was trapped under the floor on the ark
Same thing is kind of going in the bunker where you know you can't just run around and break the laws and cause riots in
in season five you'll see in fact what octavius plan is to keep the peace and how she
reprimands others in her special way for
Special way, that's not Deploy
There won't be a peaceful way possibly
With the you know healing everything that I'd say readers would throw a lot of a sea benefit
You know but now I mean we saw in that finale
You know how essential she was just getting them saving them getting off the planet do you think that in this situation?
They've been in all these years that she sort of thrived
I mean, I could feel it's a small group up there, but she would be a very key member of that group
you know ravenous is so special because she is so smart and she
You know is a key ingredient
I feel in the hundreds makes and for their survival
But I think also you know bill raven so smart you know her heart weighs on her a lot
The only reason why everyone is in Spain is because of reason Ravens, leg Clavicle myself
that it was just like more like
Some someone come pick me out because I want to go to bunker and her friends are like yeah of course
We'll be there in ten minutes and boots were tough now
What do we do so I think Raven has a lot of responsibility for everyone's?
Well-being he's Dave, and that's why you know her to humans this Facebook finale was so important for her and now in space
it's a lot for her to make sure that everyone's survivable and that we can hopefully get back down to the Earth and
wasn't a visible again and
She pritchard you kind of like Octavia if you were
Murphy was an outsider character for a long time that sort of changed a lot last season
He was sort of making amends with Raven right Nia
Yeah, come on, and then we thought even bondi uses internal works and stuff out. You know Jesus
It's really convenient
I feel like that's a character that will especially be fascinating to see a cute in six years because now he was
With these people do you think that he might be really change from all this a hundred percent?
I mean, I think all of us have to change up their league instead of six year jump is some is a great challenge
but it's also really freeing of a lot of ways and kind of
Kind of taken the shackles off of you of all the decisions. You've made with your character over six years
I mean a lot of therapy can happen in that time you can know that you can leave behind a lot of
What we've been doing, or keep some of it if you want
but obviously he's going to change because
He's so good in kind of like the pressure cooker
situations and thriving with his life on the line every day and now in space more so just
Living day to day and making it to the time they can go back home
that's very different for him, so I'm curious to see if
Now that he has nothing that kind of like fight against can he really just be part of a happy family
I'm curious to see how that goes
Is he bored?
little
Troublemakers, oh he's got to find a way to have some fun
You know Chris
You know it is funny when you think about the timeline of the shows because it was just a few months with the characters
So it's like thinking about a tough few months for monty
Found his dad died had to shoot his possessed mom his best friend died in his arm
Diello wasn't what's your what's your question, and it's not to be monty know my question is actually about
Harper and monty and just the fact that you know would that make that connection even stronger
Given sort of all the loss that he's gone through I think that harper is Monty's
Main lifeline at the current moment and has been for six years I think
Given the loss of Jasper if he lost harper as well
I'm not sure he would have made it out of Arcadia
So I think that he owes or his life and she chose him
And I don't know what the results one of the last six years has been
I hope they're still together
but even if they're not they
Have you skated everything they had because I think they deserve that I know he knows maybe mocking butter fear together now
We can cry a lot can change in secures
dean this is such an ambitious show you know you look at the finale and how much you had going on is it just a
continuing fun
but also crazy
Challenging things to work on this series and see how much they throw you and how much they're doing within you know forty four minutes
A week you guys haven't met him before
But this man is like very responsible as well these days inferred for the kick-ass show that is 100. Yeah
You know one episode that really stands out to me this past season in the entire series actually is die all by Merrily
Maybe in the conclave episode
It's typical hundred fashion
It was also pretty merciless
And you lost a lot notable characters
Jason at what point developing keyboard as you know that you want to do that to worry that episode?
Pretty early on that was kind of you know every season
We have these tentpole moments of reining for that was the big one one of the big ones last year was written by Aaron wake
In Bergen mcentire Great writers my number two's on the writing staff
And dean directions that he'll really just it's as good as we've got I think it was
It was everything came together murray was awesome. She really encouraged her ass off again
I mean, I probably more great time than she's ever had
and you know we just
When I look at that, I feel like we've done this now for five years your team in Vancouver is amazing everybody sort
All the actors are titling it's really fun to be working in a show now where we know what we're doing
We know you know what we can do. We know how far we can push them. I don't try to push too hard beam
know why I thought I'd like to try to challenge everybody so you we can have this sort of
pelty
That episode was also, sort of a T14
Echo who I don't think any we could see could have guessed where her path was going to go?
Talk about you know what you said to do with her there, and how things sort of change further there
I think instead of me answering that why don't we bring out a special guest
They're tasi our hello there
So yeah, yeah I've been saying one of you heard you guys were cheering in the posse is now. It's regular Java Show
Echoed a girl in the cage and season two a lot changed what we think of her we know about her
Oh, it didn't like for you to kind of track tracker this entire way and see where she's gone
Hello
It's been amazing
every time we got a script those nervous to
to
Explore more in Teco and give life to that character, and she was always the character that I felt really
Strongly about she was sassy she's cool. I love it when she's bad not felony face
You want an echo eats for breakfast? Oh?
How is years ago? That's a week you yeah?
Okay, mia got ones needed here. I got the biggest movie ever you who will Spin a totally favorite season fun
But yeah, it's very credible
Lindsey I referenced this why don't I introduce you but yeah, this is Raven reyes
And I'm alive with such a great moment on the show
You know let's talk about that episode the other side which was you know another Raven goes through hell episode
But only I can build that that entire sequence of the water crawling across the floor
that
Badass I feel like you know I so. I so love with this show because
It's my own selfish after needs because they're constantly
Challenged these physically emotionally
Act
Acting truly, and that absolutely helped them cuz I'm in this tank that I asked to be freezing to death and have these really emotional
Figment of my iMagination have been losing my mind
And then I kill myself
and then I resurrect it with the electric shock underwater and have a heart attack and throw myself over it and crawl to a
defibrillator that the cross
oh
Ilana stick it on the right place and Jolt my heart back to life because of my heart Murmur
And I want to talk to my friend
it was it was insane, but it was honestly like
In you suggested that one. He was with me every step of the way, and it was you know
We did some really cool things to where I just felt like I was coming back on the ground
He walked me through this like a magic story about what I'm going through my mind
And it was it was kind of a surreal experience that I just really I just feel like no other show
I'm going to be able to get and do that like free. It's like. It's a dream job like what do you do that never?
So it is then I would call it hell venom
Heaven
Pinaster way yeah dirty actor I think
Definitely, that's certainly something that this cast goes through more than any cast really I've ever worked with we do so much physical stuff on
a show a lot of them do
80% 90% of their own stunts, which is kind of amazing
the weather in
Vancouver starts out really hot and then it gets rainy and then it gets snowy and cold
And we're out in it 14 hours a day, so it never wants. I mean, they're pros, and it's it's really been fun I
believe last year
Sitting on this very stage
Version of Chris you know there was a lot of talk in other people's - about lamenting cuz you to like never work together
So, what was it like you?
Finally get to work together and the fact is that you know
Your characters had to deal with some of the old issues because they hadn't been on screen together
Yeah, I mean one time. We'd been together before season four woods. I just tried to kill his best friend
Or like coughing yeah
Goldberg
Yes, of course. I think that was where we had to one thing we had so we had to play with that frasier eerie force
Jason's hands with that one but forcing us down so glad it was good idea we had it's funny
You know there's so many actors in the cast that it's hard to find you know
I took that surprised me that they had never been in a cBs and though when I wrote the scene
I did have to sort of go back to the beginning and sort of call after that moment in episode
what would that so 103 103 is this one that was the one that fell away was out of
The Camp and I took it right myself to leader
and exactly what think west I think say
How do you feel about me I?
Please the fit no, it's been great. It's been great Richard. I'm glad to finding out screen time this is yeah, they're little year anniversary
if I preview
100 Soap Opera they were network get bored in space
Sofia
Can you talk about you know it just echo like?
These people do not have a lot of reasons to trust
I go clearly it was a very tense situation even her joining them so or you know
I don't know how much you know about what it's going to be like the six-year job
But are you excited to see how things that developed because that's so much time that it's just a small group of people spending together
Yeah, I actually am thinking about that a lot like who should become friends with
Like I was thinking would she become friends with Louisa
Or would she become friends with other castigation be close to raven for some reason. Yes
I feel like these two girls or girls a guessing times a
very resourceful
They are dad to see those two like becoming friends and having alliances where
two
Years of a long time yeah, we forget together break up the back together
together
That's the thing you know Jason knight. I'm I don't have the shipping question. That's not my deal, but
six years
Yes, you use a lot of rocket look at when it is coupled the reason were not part of a couple
How many things have changed?
Like I said things people break up, you will get back together full
Fool around I mean they do have secures of time to kill and there's not a lot to do
Jolyon Faithful Ravens really long oh
And then I have to ask you this. I hope you've ended but uh you know whether it be the bunker or the rocket
Her baby, that's going to be showing up with you. I know you would sing a little would be from
Another well no, but clark has one you
Won't have to get pregnant, but she has to be preventing child together fun passport
We're going to go to audience questions if you visit, but has depression or later. I'm going to have
Randy Fox Acne Podcast is everyone going to undergo a change that Puritans amplified
Emphasized of the six year jump like how clark cut her hair and color part of its will there be will be some eye patches
So no bowlegs
It's actually a lot because usually we're picking right back up where we left off except right things the one season
We found is are killing panic oriented
and so they're literally these guys go off on their hiatus and they to movies or they relax you whatever do when they grow their
hair and they cut their hair and they dye their hair
We gotta get it back to where it was you know exact exact moment, but this season is different
And I've really talked to all of them about
What are they because anything is possible?
After six years so I'm open to it bob and I have been talking
Guys to kind of crazy
Aha, well the funny thing is is dialed in already have already know that you know
It's pressuring me for some weird hair dude. You want to share with them. No, I don't want if you're going
You clearly don't like it. We've done that. I don't agree
Well, Bob we have an also ghost because other people asked about the appearance change?
But I got a very specific one from hath eternal, baby saying
Oh bellamy has a beard or a lot - yeah like it is not just a back
Door game though being very back. I can't really
Love that one on this, but I can't really grow a bit
So you know we're kind of discussing that now and factoring it in terms of bh, budget
donation we don't have a budget Bobby appeared with
Big cypress, I got a big montage. Oh, yeah, he'll get fired up
What's your talking with a pair?
Feel cool. Yeah
Yeah, I mean are you down with that this week -?
Yeah
we got -
open on a close-up of the impression is my -
Yeah, I mean, I'm open to it
Okay, cool mustache
sure
Just really we have to succeed Minor felonies like carving that good thing now
Connie on the radio really
Asked a relevant ask that it's inevitable that we get flashbacks during the six year time jump
Would that be how the season starts does it start from right where we left off might there be some flashbacks catching us up?
Yeah, they'll be flashbacks for sure
There's a lot of very pivotal
Emotional intense moments that we will have missed in that six year period I think it's important to see some of them
not going to spoil the premiere yet, but
We will come to understand
how all of them
Became the characters that we will see in the premiere
Yes, that does include flashback. Hi. I'm Jonah what I was wondering is that all the character of the show are so complex?
They wanted them later funny. What's your favorite had to do tortures or trees of your character?
I don't know. I like a headlock clock
Resilience, I guess is something
That I like and there's a lot of selflessness to her which makes me happy
I mean I
Admire only a belamis present if you had to get up and everyday no he's made so many important choices and still
Try and assist and get things done, but the thing that I personally like about it
The most is his ability to hold on to guilt I mean
No, but honestly it sounded fun to play in that realm and everything so weighted down so as an actor
I I like it when he's in tune with that part of himself
so yeah
sounds I
like how
Incredibly flawed Octavia is and she's always brave in the face of fear. I like that about it. I
love
Ravens will I feel like she when she puts her mind to something. She is unstoppable and it's
admirable that
You know because I think for me like I don't get bogged down, but you know Raven reyes
never gives up
I love it. I
Don't do it
It's kind of similar time okay?
It's kind of similar to will or brazilian, but as there is relentlessness
It's not even like a calculated resilience. It's just this pure
like
animalistic
Will to continue whatever
Grade she's on the pocket, and I never had exactly how groups never done and I think
Yeah, he's just he's like a wild dog. I love them my God
my God sexy gail
Did you all know that monty can make alcohol from scratch?
Makes Moonshine in like three weeks down on the ground. I think that's pretty cool is it
Is that your favorite characteristic yeah? I?
Think I like at those strengths and her loyalties most
She never backed down from a fight. She's always protecting her plan first and
Yeah
Thank you very much
next question see
Hi, I'm Aj
You guys can't give me a heart attack with like all the years of stuff. I can't take it
Oh, but I hope you guys never die. What did you do?
How would you want to go out and I see the characters other?
Someone else talking son might go out the way raven would God have to go out stay
We are talking with character
You personally would like me. Yeah, it's down at this thing yeah to be back behind I
Want bellamy to kill them I think we've come a long way
But I think if there is their happiness, I like double turn or something alright
And you have to just put me down
And I think that be read like a come a long way like I like you can yell all right, right?
Yeah, yeah, one way or another?
I think we do right you could be right of one of us to have the other eventually and ask Nona
- building just have a misstep and fall off the edge of the cliff
Thank something like you would
I think I'd say the only just bought four horsemen gallant, and I get stepped on or something it would hurt her ego
Less and to get taken out by some Brie. Oh
Yeah
God, I don't know I
Mean realistically collectively some sort of grand
self-Sacrifice
yeah, it's not that funny but
You would go out alone problem. No, I could Jennifer. Yeah. Yeah, who Chris talked to?
one two three
one two
three
Hey, okay
I'd like for equitable monty in sleeper hold kind of accidentally take him out
no, one's like
Navigated a peacefully in his sleep
I
Like your costume by the way
Thank you very much
Big question all right man hey, hey
Okay
Hi
So we know that secures past and clark is now mom
but I was just wondering what type of
Parenting styles does the car have and it has been six years so all of you might be surrogate parents. What kind of
Parenting style will your characters clarks a cool mom
Yes
Mom come on
Let me get our man. Don't be a mess yeah. Oh yeah, that's like at page five. We're like okay. Now. This is a rifle
How to drive a robot luther connors are coming to remember like yeah, raise her to be?
Prepared in case yeah, yeah
Better job with her than me Charlotte. We were terrible only we
Can tell that she's privates in the real know that she's telling her tonight stories that also end with you know murder and death
Yeah
Thank you
There's no moving the clark has been telling stories up you guys these are Maddie's heroes when we when we started
That was going to be another Letdown when she painted
Your belly fat mustache
I was just wondering now the show is kind of come full circle with
The original art residents being the grounders what parallels are we conceived between season one and the upcoming season?
That's a really good question yeah one of the things that excited me about this idea bringing these prisoners into the world was that
five seasons ago these guys with prisoners and now clark is the grounder in the woods who's
watching these people step out very different cast of characters that they're about to have to deal with but that
Parallel will continue for sure we'll play with that
Quite a lot this season, and they'll realize it
I think the bellamy is going to have to help clark come to see that you know there's we have to do things differently now
Because she just wanted to protect her child. She just wants to protect her home, so
Thank you very much
Can I hold your baby balloon we're working on America?
Our question is a 6 years to be a long time sit around in a big kitchen whether you're underground
She wants to meet you
Super bot. I'll introduce you our new center. Enjoy all right. This is why we have no babies on the show
But we've got one if you need bread ha ha ha ha she's used to make character. Look good
The life is like trying her in it
All right
we have a running series that certainly miller and Jackson are going to get together with some of the grounders of informa Wwe
So what other kinds of hobbies you think your characters are going to put together -?
uh I
Think that without whiskers you guys what I'll not pitch to the story. I'm old habits die hard. Let's go back to being a janitor
grooming again
It's really all about the cleanliness
Yeah, that's gonna be spent yeah
And a big conference like Freddie Mercury yes. Yeah, no joke which was a
Frame where he's and then also are you do pull-ups anyone whatever?
anyone Else I
was - like raven for her to learn to
The fight you know you don't only be raving. It's you too much combat, so I know you
All right, then I'm good
Alright, I think it will be our final question
Hey guys and Fellies memory oh
You've got potential reasons. Yeah
Your wedding. I wanted you wanted
My question is actually since you talked about fighting
I mysterious, how often you get to rehearse before you buy what the process is to kind of learn suffice
And then like I put this on today, and it seems hard to fight and like see if awareness
How did you do that before you actually shot or was it like step into it wheels the swords kind of thing
this is a very good question um
The cool thing is about sword fighting to basically put it in a quick nutshell here. Is that it's kind of like learning dance
Like there's the alert a dance routine
And that's the way it is and it's all numbered out and we do it slowly
And I've named all the moves so I write them down and when I get home
I was given a wooden sword as a gift
And I just sit in my living room when I practice so one's called like Chick-fil-a the Sam
and I call another one like silly name so I remember it and
I memorize my fights, but sometimes you get a ton of time and sometimes you don't have schedules change and stuff
But if you really just I don't know I'm really good at a really useless life skill on my luggage horse fighter
Yeah, there's always there's always stuff rehearsal
we have
You know we find time on days when they're not working there at the end of days when they're not doing the stunts to go
Over to Marshall virtues our stunt coordinator has been season one and is amazing
And he puts them through their paces and they rehearse
Sometimes we don't have time for that. She's right and
They just make this stuff up today. It'll call it on the on the big ones for sure
We do it because look if safety is always an issue
You know with the stunt work, so on the big stunt sequences like in dialed
I merrily we each one of those was a little dance
we
The director who was me on that one works with Marshall and says this is kind of what I'm thinking
I want it to look like this. He goes and reverses with the stunt guys shows it to me
Videotapes it and shows it to me I go
I like that that's change that and then he brings these guys in and they get to learn and then I look at it again
I say yeah, that's exactly what I want. We show up on the day sometimes
It's exactly will be rehearsed sometimes where we will tell you what can I do it like this?
And so we'll change one or two little moves. That's basically how it goes I?
put a clip of Marine or living room like
Thanks, Angela